my pick is the hit cbs sitcom bob hearts
abishola it's giving us an inside look
at nigerian culture
in a dramatic two-part episode i can't
wait for you guys to see it
really my pick is falake
[Music]
excellent yeah well done i'm nuts about
her she plays abhishola a nigerian nurse
who falls in love with her former
patient that would be bob at the
beginning of the season
abhishola proposes to bob but it's not
happily ever after just yet why because
she is still married
to a man named teo in nigeria in this
preview
teo makes a surprise visit to the u.s
rap ro
take a look you know what kind of rental
car they gave me
what a jeep oh no
that day in mexico it was the most rain
i'd ever seen in my life
it would have been fine if we had a car
with a roof on it
ah and you persuaded me to wear my white
dressed id
even angry and covered in muck you were
the most beautiful woman in acapulco
so beautiful the hotel doma and pota was
homeless
you're so good hello folake it's so good
to see you again
let me tell you when i looked at that
episode i kept thinking about that dress
where
whose is it i want to get that but
listen we're here to talk about you
because
i so love the show i so love you in the
show i've told you that many times
before
and this season began with abhishola
proposing to bob
so how is that going to go why do you
think that these two are such a good
match
i love the blending of the cultures in
the show
good morning gail good morning thanks
for having me good to see you again
um why do i think this uh this couple
this match works is because
it's rooted in love the most important
thing in the world
uh you see two strong people come
together
uh they they've been well abhishel in
her case has been the caregiver for her
family
and so is bob and uh in each other they
find
like a balance and an appreciation for
for life a new appreciation for life
yeah but then her
husband shows up number one i think it's
interesting
we didn't know she had i didn't know she
had a husband and he shows up and it's
very clear he's coming back to take his
woman
and so i think this adds a whole nother
layer of humor to this show
oh no well it remains to be seen if he
is in fact here to take his woman or not
or he's going to be successful if you
need so
uh yeah that that is the brilliance of
chuck laurie and our writers there's a
twist here
and um and the show starts to take a
sort of dramatic
turn which is unusual for a sitcom which
makes our show a little bit of a hybrid
but go ahead it gets it gets real in the
next two episodes it gets
pretty emotional and pretty intense okay
i've already seen the first two episodes
but this
is the thing that i like about the show
because it's so layered
you've got uh black americans black
women
you have nigerian women you have the two
cultures that combine and there's humor
there
you have bob's wackadoodle family that
is rich and a lot of humor there
but i like for instance you there's a
great line where you talk about
you're riding in the car with your
friend and bob and you say to your
friend bob doesn't want you in the car
anymore he finds you annoying
and then the black friend says you know
you could have said that a different way
that's really not nice and you say
nigerians to you it's rude but to us
it's honesty
and it had me laughing out loud do you
think that that's true
oh that's very that's extremely accurate
you know people have um when i first
came to america
i had people who were offended by some
of the things that say
until they realized i was nigerian
because they had experience
with other nigerians they're like oh
okay which is normal
but i've had to draw i've had to
actually adjust there is a language
barrier that exists
nigerians can be straight to the point
it's like a fast-paced community and
you don't have time to waste the things
to be done you just need to communicate
as
effectively as possible and move on and
um and that doesn't translate
as quite polite here and also i find
that in america
um you need to you constantly need a
smile on your face and be perky
your parents wanted you they actually
wanted to be to be a lawyer right
yes my father was uh one of the top
legal minds in the country he was a
senior advocate of nigeria he named me
after her
and so when you how did the conversation
go when you said no i'm staying in the
in the states to
to pursue art oh i lied
um i told them i was i was i was at the
city college of new york
studying economics and i was going to go
on to law school but then
i was i i changed to a theater major
and i started teaching myself guitar but
they didn't know that until i graduated
yeah and you have a whole other side
that people are discovering you have a
new song out right now you sing
i didn't know you sing whoa i i yeah
i love music um music i studied audio
engineering in uh
in new york at the institute or at the
institute of audio research
and um i love music um and i taught
myself qatar
i released my single melanie
we were we were listening to it you know
when oprah was breaking into this
business they wanted her to change her
name to susan
and she refused did anybody ever say to
you you know you ought to have changed
your name it's on
us to get the name right not on you i
was wondering did anybody ever say you
should change your name
oh yeah i got that i got that a few
times but our names are very powerful in
europe
right culture so there was no way i was
going to switch that well good on you we
will get it thank you very much felake
always good to see you you can watch bob
hart's abishola monday night at 8 30 7
30 central
right here on cbs